j'accueille maintenant gaspard proust
pour l école de la vie
[Applaudissements]
talent ouais
super l'extase aux joies allons-y
alors cette semaine il ya tellement rien
que je vais commencer par la rubrique
cinéma façon je suis obligé à cesser
canal la cérémonie des césar c'est super
chouette tout ça
non mais il ya un côté très ludique un
filet des trucs qui pèse 10 kg de bronze
à des vieux qui doivent les trimballer
sans se prendre les pieds dans leurs
robes de soirée tout manque plus que les
vachettes et la voix off de nathalie
simon ont frisera le sommet du glam
agricole
près j'ai mes réserves esthétiquement à
césar c'est pas dire à un oscar qui a
subi un crash test
pour les césar c'est toujours pareil
hein c'est un film qui est nominé dans
toutes les catégories et qui au final
reçoit rien du tout alors cette année
c'était camille redouble très bon film à
seul défaut il ya une heure
quarante-cinq en trop
alors je n'ai pas vu ses co totalement
gratuit ce que julien c mais à l'heure
du tout payant un peu de gratuité dans
l'humour ne fait pas nécessairement
demain les césar qui se pavanait parce
qu'ils accueillaient kevin costner ça
c'est vrai c'est du rêve du glamour je
rappelle qu'à l'époque de danse avec les
loups edith cresson était premier
ministre
ça c'est la france c'est la france est à
hollywood ce que la province et à paris
on a l'impression d'avoir al pacino
alors qu'on nous envoyait blinn leclerc
engagement semaines difficiles la france
a perdu stéphane hessel dont je pense
que tout le monde voit le père castor du
lieu commun engagé
stéphane hessel un mec tellement engagée
que lorsqu'il est né il portait déjà un
nom qui évoquait les poilus
indignez vous aviez vous qu'ils disaient
c'est vrai la paix c'est mieux que la
guerre le bien est supérieur au mal le
capitalisme c'est kaka ou petites
crottes flûte il est l'heure de changer
mes couches à le grand âge ce coma
éthylique sans alcool en tout cas c'est
un triste destin franchement révélé à 92
ans mort à 95 3 ans de célébrités
dans son malheur une chance trop âgé
pour faire ce plh
bon je dis ça à moi son bouquin son
fascicule j'ai adoré at-on jamais rendu
un si bel hommage à du helvetica police
enfin pour une fois que la littérature
s'engage aussi sincèrement contre la
presbytie pourquoi bouder notre plaisir
alors façon c'était un résistant assez à
gages d'une attaque habilité en france
jeudi en france pour pouvoir dire
n'importe quoi c'est simple entre 40 et
45 soit a fait le mariole dans le maquis
soit à planquer des juifs dans sa cave
c'est
une fois que tu as fait ça même si tu te
mets à raconter que la terre est plate
tout le monde va trouver génial c'est
comme ça c'est comme ça qu'est ce tu
veux christine c'est comme ça fait
penser à nina hagen jeune je dise ça
m'empêchait
bref politiques gauche rien à dire ils
sont impeccables certes le chômage bat
un nouveau record mais il faut être
honnête c'est un peu trop tôt pour
mesurer les effets du mariage gay sur
l'emploi
j'adore ce pays
droite on a eu des nouvelles de françois
fillon alors lui il a trouvé un nouveau
truc monté sur des tribunes convoquer
des réunions pour expliquer pourquoi il
sera candidat à rien
françois fillon ou l'homme qui est mène
pas être là
alors il paraît qu'il va à la rencontre
des français il va labourer le pays
aller à la rencontre des vrais gens
c'est un peu le leitmotiv des comment
peut-on vouloir être proche des gens en
oubliant que la vraie souffrance c'est
de ne pas trouver de taxi à 2 heures du
matin samedi boulevard saint germain
glamour marine le pen
marine le pen aimerait qu'on reconnaisse
aussi le caractère parfois utile de la
colonisation à la balle a pas tout à
fait tort la colonisation c'est un peu
comme la torture en algérie on n'est pas
sûr que les bourreaux vont te laisser un
bon souvenir en revanche on est sûr
qu'ils vont te laisser un compteur edf
économie alors le patron de coca cola
est venu au secours de la france et des
ouvriers il a dit que les français
travaillent bien plus que trois heures
par semaine tu m'étonnes qu'il est ravi
avec la main d'oeuvre française rappelle
que son métier consiste à faire des
bulles d'un moment on
faut être honnête
impasse peillon veut réformer les
vacances d'été c'est quand même fou
supprimer la dernière raison valable qui
n'ont envie de faire prof
alléger les semaines alléger le
programme allégé les devoirs à la fin il
sortira plus des élèves mais de
l'aspartame que ce sera le train le goût
de l'intelligence avec 0% culture
générale de danser voilà l'avenir
romantisme dsk
alors une ex maîtresse de dsk qui pour
un énième bouquin sur lui alors ses
écrits par marcela iacub ce qu'on voit
la photo c'est diam's après une chimio
alors la fille c'est pas n'importe qui
c'est chercheuse au cnrs tous assez
c'est assez rassurant quoi il monte en
gamme quoi de la femme de ménage à la
philosophe c'est la preuve qu'il aurait
fait un bon président quand ils arrivent
à pénétrer toutes les couches sociales
j'y pense faisant sept mois de relation
pour retranscrire des ébats sur le
papier comme quoi être chercheuse au
cnrs c'est pas forcément un gage de
rapidité d'esprit
et tout ça au final pourquoi l'ana elle
est tellement romancière du dimanche
qu'au bout de trois pages tapis j'ai
qu'ils agissaient de dsk
du coup forcément une amende de 60 mille
euros c'est vraiment le coup de maître
il va lui rester un sacré pactole à la
fin à la meuf kotor l'api sato en sept
minutes elle touche le jackpot l'autre
aile mais sept mois à pondre un truc qui
lui fera toucher à peine de quoi
s'offrir un abonnement club med gym
conseillers
avec
[Musique]
merci pour cette spontanéité
alors ya sept mois alors évidemment le
l'avocat a négocié un truc génial c'est
qu'il faut faire figurer la mention
atteinte à la vie privée alors ça
figurer dans chaque exemplaire du livre
ça c'est vraiment la victoire de dsk
quoi le tipi se bat pour sa dignité et
son avocat obtient que dans chaque
bouquin on dise aux lecteurs et aux
ailes gros porc c'est bien mon client
voilà alors bonne nouvelle de la semaine
passée la fin de la chronique quoi pour
vous je sais pas mais pour moi y'a pas
photo
a bel et bien que ce blog était un peu
ce bleu